here's how you can turn ground beef into
flour who asked for this content so you
want to go animal base but you just
can't quit junk food you want to eat
stuff that looks like this well I got
you I am so sorry to yuck someone's yum
but personally I would not want to eat
something that looked like that you
start by cooking your ground beef at low
temperature cuz you don't want it to
burn then you're going to strain the fat
off then take your lean beef gravel put
on a baking pan and set it in a
dehydrator I'm sorry did we just call
that beef gravel never have I ever been
tempted to eat a food described as the
same substance on my driveway now you
can make better versions of stuff you
love like this meat cereal right here
meat
cereal no I don't know if dried out beef
with milk brings you Joy amazing you do
you but as a dietitian this ancestral
carnivore diet honestly freaks me the
out not only is making cereal out
of beef about as environmentally
unsustainable of a diet as they come but
this low fiber highs saturated fat
dietary pattern is about as
scientifically backwards as it gets if
you must make beef flour fine but not in
lie of plants next